hi i'm jay kitchener i'm a senior
technical staff member here at ibm cloud
and the lead architect for ibm cloud
satellite an exciting
product that we have available for you
now in ibm cloud
what is ibm cloud satellite ibm cloud
satellite is a platform service that
allows us to expand the reaches of ibm
cloud
to infrastructure outside of ibm cloud
data centers
a powerful technology if you want to be
able to consume cloud services
but you need to be able to use it closer
to your data where that may be
in your on-premises data center on
another cloud provider where you may
have a data lake
or potentially it's sitting on your desk
like i have right here
today i've got three intel nux that i'm
going to be using to set up a satellite
location
which i think is pretty cool it's kind
of like any sort of
uh store kiosk that you might need to
set up and it's a great example of the
power of using distributed cloud with
ibm cloud satellite
so to get started the first thing i need
to do is log into the ibm cloud console
and navigate over to ibm
cloud satellite once i'm there i'm going
to go ahead and create a new location to
represent my desk
i'm going to go ahead and click the
create location button give this
location a name
and click create pretty straightforward
now
once that location is up and running
what i need to do is bring some of my
infrastructure on board
to do that i'm going to navigate over to
the hosts section which is the concept
that we use in ibm cloud satellite to
represent
the idea of systems that are outside of
ibm cloud as the host
the first thing i need to do is click on
attach host i'm going to go ahead and
download this post provisioning script
and then once i've got that in my hand i
can go apply that post provisioning
script to any system on the planet that
could be
in another cloud provider it could be in
your on-premises data center
or in this case i want to get it
bootstrapped onto these intel nuts that
are sitting on my desk
now to do that i've built a custom image
that will automatically
carve up these systems into virtual
machines and bootstrap them with my post
provisioning script
so uh all i need to do is get this onto
that usb
key insert it into my intel nox and go
ahead and power them on
now i'm going to go ahead and go through
that process for all three of these
because i want a highly available setup
so i can do maintenance by removing
these later on
but that's pretty much it
now that those systems are online we can
see they're all
up here and ready for me to use in my
satellite location and i'm going to go
ahead and get one from each of those
systems assigned to be my satellite
control plane
this is really the heart of ibm cloud
satellite that allows us to build a
secure
way for us to go manage cloud services
into your ibm cloud satellite location
now i've got these hosts assigned my
location is in a normal state
and i'm ready to start using ibm cloud
services let's go ahead and take a look
at what that experience is like i'm
going to navigate over to the ibm cloud
catalog
and i could choose any of the ibm cloud
satellite enabled services that we have
available
today we're going to demonstrate red hat
openshift on ibm cloud but it could
other be other services as well like
our postgres database or potentially
maybe some of our
cloud pack for data as a service options
as well so let's go ahead
into the catalog to red hat openshift on
ibm cloud and we can see
i still have my traditional cloud
service options where i can provision
into ibm cloud data centers like a vpc
but i've also got the satellite option
available to me as well
so i'm going to go ahead and choose
satellite choose my new location i
created and go ahead and give that a
name
and then create that openshift cluster
now i can navigate over to my openshift
clusters in ibm cloud
and we can see i've got a number of
clusters in here some of them are
located in ibm cloud
some of them are in satellite locations
but this one is on my desk
let's go ahead and see what that looks
like i'm going to click over to my
cluster here and i can see i've got all
the normal
service options that i would have for
red hat openshift and ibm cloud i can
update the version of this cluster to
the latest version of red hat open shift
or i can go in and perform maintenance
on my worker nodes as well like
providing updates to them but the really
powerful tool
is that you've now got red hat openshift
as a service
running in infrastructure in your data
center or in this case
on mydesk i get the standard user
experience with single sign-on from ibm
cloud
into red hat openshift and all the usual
tools that i would find
in in red hat openshift are available
i've got all my logging tools my
monitoring tools
the registry all of the development
tools that are available to users of red
hat openshift
so very powerful tool that we've got
available to us here that allows us to
really expand the reach of ibm cloud
and the powerful cloud services that we
provide
in this case on my desk but remember it
could be on any infrastructure in the
world running red hat enterprise linux
thank you for watching if you have
questions please drop us a line below if
you want to see more videos like this in
the future
please like and subscribe